bitcoin is down 58 year-to-date so is  bitcoin finished well let me ask you are  these blue chip stocks finished netflix  is down 70 year-to-date shopify is down  75 year-to-date facebook is down 51  amazon 37 and apple is down 24  year-to-date so if this doesn't make you  think that these companies are over then  you shouldn't think that bitcoin is  finished either the world is in a mess  right now we've just had a two-year  lockdown supply chain issues soaring  inflation globally hitting 40-year highs  there's a war going on between russia  and ukraine all these things are going  to affect markets globally in all asset  classes so hold your bitcoin tight  because better days are coming